it's the longest river on the world in
the world at 4,000 miles long going
through difficult countries where there
were two war zones and so we we rushed
and we just totally missed out on
everything that we went straight past
the pyramids you know there's a
triangular thing over on the left boom
straight past and yeah all the way down
we missed out on everything and so for
Joe to suddenly be able to get us with
all the permissions to see what tourists
normally can't see in the middle of the
pyramids etc and Luxor and all the
things that we've missed out on in our
rush to get down and back to the army
was a wonderful chance
jo-anne imagine there are quite a few
challenges because it wasn't just
looking at the pyramids was it it's a
very challenging environment on this
route I think we had more thoroughly
enjoyable times than we did scary I mean
it you're always you're always kind of
on this trip you're always there's a
danger everywhere and suddenly they
would come out of left field
like driving a very old defender too
fast on a road and something happening
rather quickly and taking me off the
road and things that you can't really I
I was behind Joe when he was driving
down a straight tarmac road at 60 miles
an hour in the defender and I was behind
by about a hundred yards and quite
suddenly this vehicle gang of 60 came
off the road darn into soft sand just
like that we had to get to our
destination before it became dark
because it gets quite tricky at night in
Egypt driving and dark and so we decided
to hit this lone road in the middle of
the desert which is a single track piece
of tarmac they would get us to our
destination quickly so we were doing
quite getting there quite a speed and we
a piece of equipment had got locked up
on the front wheel there was a tow rope
and it it basically sent me straight off
the road and nearly tipped and nearly
got pretty unstuck but ran had always
painted this thing called the black
picture which is worst case scenario
that can
happen when you're on an expedition and
I just thought it was one of his tests I
thought was the bad picture I thought he
had wrapped something around it - did it
teach me what it was like to kill to
kill my cousin if you can imagine your
going at 60 miles an hour and your front
wheel bursts the vehicle is going to go
bump like that
totally suddenly and I watched this
happen just ahead of me and I knew my
cousin was dead on the outside what did
he find most enjoyable obviously the
driving sounded like it was quite sticky
at points but he had to go through and a
lot of tombs there are encounters with
scorpions and dangerous anomalies it was
like an Indiana Jones kind of film every
day connecting with the people of Egypt
is a big thing especially in this world
of division and culture and faiths as
lovely to be and predominately Muslim
country connecting with the people and
their extraordinary culture but yeah
being spending the night in the Great
Pyramid was just remark like to pinch
myself and and the tunnels of El Ninos
is where the is they've only just
recently discovered these mummies and
hundreds of tombs that they think might
be the next Valley of the Kings it was
extraordinary we were the first film
crew to go in there and see that and
literally crawling through tunnels and
coming across mummies and sarcophagi and
and lots of scorpions but I got every
day was just just epic I think it's such
a shame that a few terrorists just a few
terrorists in a wonderful country where
we found that the Christians and the
Islam people together are just so
friendly would that's not that what we
get told in the newspapers the Coptic
churches Christian churches and the
Muslim mosques right next door to each
other all over the place
and they're just so friendly and you get
one or two people doing terrorist stuff
ruining their whole trade on tourism
unnecessarily I would encourage people
just to go to Egypt you're not going to
get done in by terrorists and it's just
such a wonderful place with things that
like we've been talking about - the
mummies and so on going back two and a
half three thousand years old and how
they shipped 80 foot figures
from old Pharaohs 80 tons and they would
do it with little chisels and then take
them down ramps into boats on the Nile
and then deliver them like so Amazon to
people who wanted that sort of statue
some of them up north some of them down
south just incredible it's fascinating
isn't because there is this whole swathe
of programs that are being made now of
family members going on these voyages of
self-discovery
and it's about what they discover on the
trip not just about the places they they
visit but about the dynamics as well
people are fascinated by family dynamics
aren't they well that was a big thing
about this trip yes Egypt scorpions
pyramids but also what I hope an
audience might take away from this is
that maybe there's a member of family
for them that they could go down the pub
with and listen to their legacy there
aren't there uncle their grandmother
their great-grandfather to go out and
really connect with your family and
really glean their history and a history
that might be really amazing and
undiscovered so for me a big part of
that show is connecting with your family
members who wherever they might be and
get their story so you can pass that
story on to your younger generation and
so that that legacy lives and just
finally obviously this is seems like
it's just the start you see you've got a
taste for this an adventure together
soon could we see you going on more
expeditions and reliving other trips
don't know what do you got up your
sleeve room yeah I've got something up
my sleeve
and just gently and gradually I will put
it over to Joe in a nice way rather than
giving him a black picture like what
normally does just no ice floes alone
for 70 days with polar bears please no
I'll keep ice right out of it